Marshall Faulk has been booked as our
first guest on tomorrow's show to
discuss this conversation about running
backs no sign reveals Marshall Faulk Pro
Football Hall of Famer all-time great
friend of the program and fantastic Ram
as well which leads me into my next
guest he is the head coach of the Los
Angeles Rams he is Sean McVeigh back on
the show how are you coach I'm doing
great rich you know Marshall Faulk was a
part of the interview process so when I
went when they first hired me it was
myself Marshall Faulk Stan Kroenke and
Kevin damoff out to dinner before I was
fortunate to get this job so I'm always
a big fan of our show because if he
didn't sign off on me I'd probably be
still in Washington maybe no kidding so
he was part of the if you will shark
tank that you had to be sitting in front
you know it showed you just the impact
and the appreciation that our
organization and mr. cocky asked for a
player of his magnitude because he's so
observant he's so well thought out the
production speaks for itself but I think
one of the concerns was you know how do
you hire a guy that 30 years old to be a
head coach and really being able to get
his perspective and fortunately when we
went to the bathroom I said hey I'll
split my salary with you to just sign
off on this that was went down in the
men's room huh
that's what you did hey that's fantastic
oh my gosh so now I mean now you're wise
and what 33 year old coach right now
[Applause]
years right you've aged 40 years in NFL
years I mean that is amazing too cuz you
know I sit here and I think about it we
have discussed it a lot with the Brady
signing in Tampa that 20 years between
and how we're like hey Brady might have
embellish act might might have just not
gotten along anymore I mean there's so
much of that conversation 20 years of
being together is sick is significant I
mean that would mean that you and golf
would have to be together for what
another 17 years to match that that's
right I mean it really is I mean that's
to me of the most productive quarterback
coach relationship that's occurred I
mean it really is unprecedented for the
level of consistency I mean that they've
been able to achieve I just continue to
come away impressed and you can't help
but just you know sit there and say
Touche
let's get into some nuts and bolts here
speaking of unprecedented of what's
going on in the world Sean McVeigh of
the Los Angeles Rams here on the Rich
Eisen show so are you working from home
walk me through what your day is with a
draft less than three weeks away Sean
you know it certainly is unprecedented I
think really you know guys that have
been instrumental in being able to allow
us to operate as close to the normal as
possible has been you know our IT
director Jeff graves our video
coordinator Dan to me Tristan and his
groups I'm becoming an expert on these
zoom meetings or Microsoft teams
meetings but but typically what I'm
doing is you get up you kind of you know
get a little workout in and then you
immediately dive into either meetings
with the coaches to kind of stay on
track with your installs or you're
having draft meetings which we've kind
of started up this week and you know you
just kind of jet chip away and try to
stay busy try to create a rhythm in a
routine and you know that's really what
everyday entails now just based on our
forced operate so and what about today
would have been the day obviously if the
world was normal that your offseason
workout program would have opened up
what do you know about the rules right
now about when you can figure out what
that looks like virtually coach yeah
we're kind of waiting to find that out
rich you know like the new staffs like
you mentioned you know they would have
had the opportunity to start up today
and I think we're waiting on clarity
from the league just to see all right
what level of interaction will they
allow based on kind of the agreement
between the league and the PA as far as
trying to get these guys you know their
workout bonuses but but being able to
follow the protocols to be a part of the
solution with with the coronavirus so
we're kind of waiting I think all the
steps and I've kind of talked to some
guys around the league you know it's
just set it up to where you're ready to
have virtual meetings and figure out the
best way to interact with your guys from
afar but we really haven't gotten
exactly
what that looks like but I would imagine
if we do end up agreeing on some level
of communication you'll be forced to use
the resources that we've kind of been
utilizing with our interaction amongst
our coaching staff and personnel with
these draft meetings and I think it'll
be something that we'll just take
advantage of and and adjust and adapt
like you have to anytime so technically
are you able Football legally to have
contact with golf now and just go
through stuff with him or like what what
is what does that look like not right
now
you know it's in that involuntary period
so right now we are not able to do that
quite yet rich and and really we we
actually are waiting on some clarity as
the league is working through figuring
out the specific ramifications on all
right where are we going to exactly have
to draft what are all 32 teams going to
do so we can operate on a fair playing
field but also be mindful of all the
things that are going on that are a lot
bigger than football in our world yes
and then and then I think the next kind
of thing to check off to try to be able
to address it is water what are we going
to allow specific to the offseason
program given the fact that like you
mentioned those new coaching staffs
would have opened up their offseason
programs today or had the ability to do
so well in Sean McVeigh here in the Rich
Eisen show the governor of the state of
California issued a shelter-in-place
weeks ago and the mayor of Los Angeles
did the same right around the same time
so you are not the Rams are not allowed
to be in the Thousand Oaks facility
right now I mean can you walk me through
all of that coach yeah so we haven't
been there like I said you know we've
been just working remotely there there's
been some some specific alterations that
they've been able based on guys that
need that rehab if they were injured but
but for the most part you know our
facilities are closed we're following
exactly what you know governor Newsom
and mayor Garcetti have asked to be a
part of the solution and I think it's
really important that we follow those
things and demonstrate the urgency and
the importance of staying in your home
and trying to get that you know that
that curve on the downward trend like
like you hear everybody talk about day
in and day out
and Peter King was on in our number one
Shawn he had a photograph of Andy Reid
in his office his home office his
basement office and he had a what looked
like a Stairmaster and elliptical in
there and a desk shoved up against a
door that we have no idea what's on the
other side of it what does yours look
like Shawn what does yours look you know
I in my house that's kind of set aside
where you know it's kind of where I'd
duck away and I'm able to access my film
and do all the things it's it's similar
to coach Reid setup but it's in an
actual office and I did see that picture
that Peter had last week and you know
even though I don't have as much swag
it's big red I'll try to get it what do
you what do you do you think cuz it's
interesting Shawn that there was a towel
placed on the workout machine as if it
had just freshly been used do you think
that that staged what do you think what
do you think I think he was going to
town and now he was ready to watch some
film I think I saw some some cheeps film
up there anyone doing the draft stuff
yeah yeah and there's no snacks there
too I mean he's just he's just locked in
he's literally locked in doing doing his
work man me too
Shawn McVeigh here on the Rich Eisen
show alright let's get into some of the
maneuvers that were made over the last
couple of weeks what happened with the
Rams and Todd Gurley that you guys
figured it was time to part ways coach
yeah I think you know the first thing
that you talked about rich you know when
I reflect back on it and especially this
time because you have a little bit more
time than usually is allocated to really
go back and with some of the new coaches
we have you know you're really diving
into the last three years of thumb we've
had and you know I think the first thing
that I would say is you know it's really
just unbelievable what he's done over
the five years that he was a ram I
couldn't be more appreciative of our
time together and I'm and I do think
that eventually we'll be able to look
back and really be able to cherish a lot
of the great memories that we've shared
he has been so important in the success
we've had
team and I owe a lot of that to him and
I'm forever grateful for having worked
with him you know and and sometimes you
know tough decisions have to be made I
think that he will do a very nice job
with the Falcons but you know for us the
only way I can really clear rich is
these decisions are never easy but but
more than anything I think it's
important to just represent the type of
player the person and the appreciation
for the time that we did add together
and you know that's really the kind of
what I was what I would want to
emphasize just because of what he's
meant to me and what he's meant to us
and you know the three years that we've
spent together and I mean in terms of
what he's meant I mean you want to talk
about a player who was connected into
the fan you know he has that ability
when he scores to get the fans out of
their seats maybe more so than anybody
else it's just something that was about
him or still is electrifying but I'm
gonna go there with you and the there is
something I've gone there with you
before is this an injury thing is he the
same player coach I mean it seems to be
a question that's always been lingering
about Todd Gurley you know when you look
at the amount of touchdowns he's been
able to support where he talked about
the field he has in the red zone it is
electric it is dynamic
he's a superstar and he's earned that
status just based on the charisma the
production on the field I think one of
the things that I always appreciate rich
that says as much about him as anything
is you talked about how guys handled
some tough situations are different than
what you would anticipate I think one of
the coolest reflections of Todd I think
about that NFC Championship and the way
that he handled himself after that where
he's been you know first-team all-pro
back things didn't go that way
necessarily for him personally in that
game but when you hear how he speaks
about his teammates and and those kind
of things that's what's been right about
the Rams the last couple years our guys
that been instrumental in the culture
and you know there's a lot of things
that that go into tough decisions rich
and and you know what I could say is I
just wish him the best in Atlanta I
think they got a good football player
but we're also excited about seeing that
is
committee to maybe add somebody in the
draft we ended up taking Darryl Anderson
in the third round last year that we
think has a lot of upside and when
Malcolm Browns gotten his opportunities
he's delivered in a big way you know in
the last few years and and you know and
I think adding Thomas Brown as our
running back coach I think this guy is a
great football coach he's he's had a
history of really developing a lot of
big time backs at the collegiate level
that have really transitioned into the
program nicely and I'm really excited
about watching him leave that group and
we'll see if we end up bad one in the
dress okay so that is you think a
position to potentially upgrade post
early draft there's a lot of different
directions that we could go certainly
want to be mindful to draft capital we
have right now but but but that is a
position that we'll look closely at and
whether we end up pulling the trigger
and and and being able to get one of
those guys off the board I think will
remain to be seen just based on how
things fall especially when you know
where we pick and and the value that we
place on those players with how the
draft meetings and all that go okay Sean
McVeigh here on the Rich Eisen show look
you've got your guy in golf so I'm gonna
ask you to evaluate some of these
quarterbacks and this is not going to be
at any way shape or form viewed how you
view your guide because you got your gun
but you know you know you know your
coach the former assistant who is now
the coach in Cincinnati might get borrow
the question is is how do you think
burrow fits into an offense that that
Zach Taylor is running what do you think
yeah I think what makes a good coach
rich until a Justin adapted to Joe skill
set if that's the direction they decide
to go
just watching LSU's film yeah I could
have been more impressed with just the
poise the anticipation you know I think
one of the things that really set you
know Burrell apart is in a lot of games
you know they did a great job of
spreading people out and he's
recognizing and making quick decisions
and giving guys an opportunity to run
after the catch but I was really
impressed when you look at the Oklahoma
the Clemson game you know even in some
of the early parts with the Georgia game
and the SEC Championship just his
ability to escape you
when there is a rush keeping your eyes
down the field being able to deliver
balls you know that they give guys an
opportunity to make plays down the field
recognize and if guys mess up a coverage
you know when he finds moss on the
touchdown against Oklahoma down the left
sideline guys get out of position he
makes you pay and I think he's got great
wide field vision and I think the
athleticism it's something that can
sometimes be underrated because of the
production he had just operating out of
the pocket but when he did escape his
eyes are down the field and he's able to
you know be a point guard and distribute
the ball and I thought they did a great
job and you see why they were one of the
most prolific offenses in the history of
college football and which other cubies
might you have just seen or seen film on
I guess not name two and Herbert because
we know those are guys at the top of the
draft that have maybe left off and you
think this guy has an ability to play in
the National Football League we feel
about Jared I haven't spent you know a
whole lot of time you know really you
know with the quarterback evaluation
other than when you're kind of just
watching some of the players and and you
see some crossover where you might be
studying a player and then you see that
quarterback just continue to show up
whether you're studying defensive
players or whether you're studying a
teammate on offense but you know
certainly when you see what you know you
mentioned to well you mentioned Herbert
but but I think loves a guy that that
had some some upside he has some some
skills and traits that certainly excites
you just the athleticism to be able to
throw off some different platforms you
know the ball jumps off his hand when
you just see them a and a couple flips
here and there but I don't think I've
really done quite enough deuce your
allegiance and background work on the
quarterback position as a whole I just
happen to have seen a lot of burrows
stuff because you know we've looked at
some different players I was interested
in just checking out their offense so
then what do you got for me on the
deepest position in this draft do you
think Shawn that from what you've seen
you know I think I think everybody's
made a point about the receiver position
being really deeper I can't think of the
amount of you know really quality
players that have some different skill
sets that they bring to the table but I
think when it's always helpful for me
rich to say Ari who is this guy a
comparison
two in the league that had success right
and I think you're seeing a lot of guys
at the top of the draft specific to this
wideout class that could go you know I
think you will see a lot of guys go and
those you know first 100 picks at the
receiver position that all have a lot of
things that excite you that intrigue in
and I think you're seeing different
molds of types of players that can
infect an end game from that receiver
position based on how they've been used
and how it translates for the NFL it's
amazing
I just just seen the kids up close and
personal at the combine I mean that
those receivers were just i popping and
they're all big so many of them many of
them not all of them obviously but
they're physical they're big and they
can do so much and it's amazing how
we've seen you just saw on your own
division obviously last year DK Metcalf
coming off of the you know campus and
and and bawling out it really is amazing
these receivers Sean for sure it really
is you know not to mention good use of
fun good use of fun before I let you go
Sean you know you and I know a lot of
the same people I got some intel on the
show that you are binge watching when
you are not watching film and preparing
for the draft did you want to call fit
up or you want me to say the words what
do you got for me how do you want to
handle different directions I'll let you
expose me before I double expose myself
love is blind I'm hearing you're
watching love is blind on Netflix is
that a true story and he caught me at a
moment of weakness I don't want to
confirm or deny that you've outed my
source coach but that is not that is not
the show you are a binge watching you
are not binge watching right I saw a
couple episodes of that I must admit I
thought you were gonna talk about the
tiger king okay so you are watching
you're locked into the tiger king you're
locked into that too I have seen it it
was uh you know I it was one of those
deals that I'm saying to myself as I'm
watching it I can't believe I'm watching
it and I can't stop and
I just I just can't believe it but I'm
just watching it and I'm doing it so did
you watch all of them are you locked in
all of them or I had you know I it's so
bad I saw some link that I guess there's
an extra episode coming out and I'm
probably embarrassingly tuned in about
okay Shawn it's just most of the
countries doing it but it's interesting
that love is blind Chris in case you're
wondering being singles try to find a
match and fall in love without ever
seeing each other face to face it's
interesting coach that might be the way
you draft a player this year don't you
think you know anything else if you've
watched the show rich as soon as they
actually get revealed to one another I
can immediately see the brain churning
the case for your draft with you and
less need that love will be so you know
what you do really rely on at this time
rich is the background that you're
scouts and personnel groups have done
really over the last year because their
evaluation starts years in advance they
have a great way of betting a lot of
these players and whether it be the
senior bowl of combine there's been a
lot of interaction that you know we
might not be exposed to with the pro
days and some of the things that the
coaches have but that's where the trust
comes in and do feel really good about
the work that those guys have done
thanks for the time Shawn you the man
really appreciate catching up with you
like this and let's do it again soon
let's chat soon
that sounds great I appreciate you guys
having me on right back at you that says
Shawn McVeigh head coach of the Los
Angeles Rams